you're talking about legendary battles
you had with manager Billy Martin yes
and in fact at one point you got into a
shoving match in the Anoka no never
never shouting if I would have touched
him right Howard and I knew at the time
what you know we did have a verbal
altercation we verbal battles etc as a
black man as a colored player you would
have got some [ __ ]
yes I have had a name I could have been
barred from the game I could have been
suspended you can't you cannot touch
Authority in baseball right and I was
raised that way so I never would have
put my hands on unless he hits me first
right well that's a whole different
story but you hated him right you hated
Billy Martin I didn't like him I didn't
waste my time hating people it's too
much effort
he played mind games with you I mean he
would well he you know batting fourth
the fourth position cleanup as they say
wouldn't let him keep wouldn't let
Reggie mr. Jackson do this now why why
the boy because I think that he thought
it was very important to me which it was
yes at the same time it's a special
thing at that time who's never been a
black superstar with the Yankees
although Elston Howard was a great great
player I think what you're implying is
Billy Martin had it in for you so to
speak want to put you in your place
correct by his power trip in other words
hey you want to be clean up anything
gonna happen nah I'm the boss man the
way that I became the cleanup hitter
what is Thurman Munson and Lou Piniella
went to Billy Martin's room in early
August in 1977 said Billy were
struggling you're hurting the ballclub
by not hitting this guy clean him get
out of the way and let him go and then
he wound up being 41 and 11 our last 52
games I didn't realize you two weren't
going out he never saw that's all he
never spoke to me for about a year and a
half first year and a half I was there
well he had an intermediary named Fran
Healy a catcher that came in like I
didn't play the fifth game of the
playoffs against Kansas hitting the
Yankees in 1977 hmm okay I was benched
and where's the big national thing so
rain Healy comes out of the manager's
office in it comes to me
says Reggie says you're not playing
tonight I said early I said well who's
supposed to tell me you you're the
backup catcher and Fran and Fran says no
I was in there Billy called me in he
told one of the coaches to tell you and
he wouldn't tell you
he said so I'm telling you he said now
let me tell you what you need to do you
need to go out on a bench you need to
not act upset you need to be a part of
the team the cameras are gonna be on you
you make the people and the fans will go
against you if you act so if you sulk or
whatever he said so if you have to
pretend just just be rooting for the
team because you never know you may get
in there in the ninth-inning I went in
and got a pinch-hit and helped me win
the game but must be a great feeling man
to be like you know mr. Xavier at the
same time Howard
I never what was bitter about it I never
did I told you so I did my thing
it was obvious everybody was happy and I
guess this would be the first time that
I would have anything to do with I told
you so you should have did it the first
time